ما بين جدل التاكيد والنفي بالتقدم في
تجري تكثر التساؤلات بشان مدى صمود اتفاق
السلام بين الحكومه الاثيوبيه وجبهه
التحرير تجري بعد نحو عشره ايام من توقيعه
فقط
متمرده ما اعلنه الجيش الاثيوبي عن سيطرته
على غالبيه المنطقه وتدفق المساعدات
قائلين ان هذه التاكيدات تاتي من العدم
الحكومه الاثيوبيه وعلى لسان مستشار
الرئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي للامن القومي
قالت ان 70%
تخضع لسيطره الجيش الاثيوبيه موضحه ان
المساعدات تتدفق على المنطقه وان الخدمات
قد اعيدت
التي يبلغ عدد سكانها اكثر من 5 ملايين
نسمه تعيش منذ عامين تقريبا ازمه انسانيه
خطيره بسبب الصراع والحرب
فاهلها يعانون نقص الغذاء والدواء بينما
تبقى امكانيات الحصول على الخدمات
الاساسيه بما في ذلك الكهرباء والمصارف
والاتصالات ضئيله جدا
بينما تبقى الامال معقوده على المحادثات
الجاريه في العاصمه الكينيه نيروبي بين
ممثل الاطراف المتحاربه لبحث خطه نزع سلاح
المتمردين
اتفاق السلام ينص على ان اثيوبيا ستسرع
بايصال المساعدات واعاده الخدمات كما
يتناول نزع سلاح المقاتل
ايضا على ان القوات الاثيوبيه ستدخل ميكلي
عاصمه
كذلك الى انشاء اليه للمراقبه